we must find a way to look
after one another as if we were one
single tribe the passing of chadwick
boseman has left fans
devastated not only because of the
impact of his films but because of the
lives he touched as a person
so today we're going to talk about
chadwick and his lasting legacy
right now on the ketchup since it was
announced that chadwick boseman died
from colon cancer at the age of 43 the
outpouring of love and sadness has come
from
all over the world especially from his
peers and collaborators like longtime
friend michael b jordan who wrote on
instagram i'm more aware now than ever
that time is short with people we love
and admire
i'm gonna miss your honesty your
generosity your sense of humor and
incredible gifts
and black panther writer director ryan
coogler said in a tribute that much like
the rest of us
he didn't know the details of chadwick's
illness he wrote because he was a
caretaker a leader
and a man of faith dignity and pride he
shielded his collaborators from his
suffering
he lived a beautiful life and he made
great art day after day
year after year that was who he was and
shang chi and the legend of the 10 ring
star simulio gave a cool nod when he
wrote
i want to be crystal clear without
chadwick and what he gave to his
character there is no shanxi
period my career rides on the coattails
of a great man
and of course it wasn't just friends and
colleagues who felt this loss
countless fans have shared a similar
sentiment to this twitter user who said
the way black panthers showed so many
black children that they could be the
superhero
his work really meant the world to us
thank you and to sum that up in video
form is this reposting from the ron
clark academy when a whole school found
out that they were going to see
black panther chadwick himself
understood and talked about what the
film meant to the black community like
in this interview with siriusxm in 2018
he broke down while talking about two
kids with terminal cancer that he was
communicating with during filming
who both eventually passed and how
excited they were for black panther
yeah it's it means a lot
but it wasn't just his role as t'challa
where chadwick made a difference
he played a number of historical black
figures in his short career receiving
high praise from critics and fans
each time and one fan on twitter pointed
out that his work accelerated the
representation for african americans
while
also paving the way for other pocs such
as hispanics and asians in hollywood
the first of those roles was his jackie
robinson in 2013 certified fresh 42.
the film put chadwick's name and a
well-told piece of history on people's
radars
interestingly and sadly chadwick passed
on this year's jackie robinson day in
major league baseball that normally
falls on april 15 but was rescheduled
due to kovit
and it was 73 years to the day that
jackie robinson became the first black
man
white's let play baseball you will
remember me
chadwick also played the godfather of
soul james brown in 2014's get on up
a film that is certified fresh at 80
mostly thanks to performance from
chadwick that had critics using
adjectives like
unforgettable dynamite and startling
just to name a few
when i hit that stage two people better
be ready
especially the rifle and in 2017's
marshall chadwick portrayed supreme
court justice third good marshall in the
early days of his career as a lawyer
once again in pressing critics
like rolling stones peter travers who
said charged by bozeman's dramatic
lightning
marshall gives us an electrifying
glimpse of a great man in the making
the only way to get through a bigot's
door was to break it down
but beyond his acting prowess and the
important roles that he chose chadwick
was by all accounts a very genuine and
sincere person both on set
and when he was out in public actress
brie larson echoed that sentiment on
twitter by saying he took the time to
really see how you were doing
and gave words of encouragement when you
felt unsure and many on social media
made comments like this one from sal on
facebook who said he was not only an
amazing actor but an amazing human being
hollywood lost a great one too soon one
strong example of his wisdom and ability
to speak to others can be found in this
commencement speech chadwick gave at his
alma mater
howard university in 2018. it is a
must-watch
and includes words like this purpose
is an essential element of you it is the
reason you are on the planet at this
particular time in history
your very existence is wrapped up in the
things you are here to fulfill
whatever you choose for a career path
remember the struggles
along the way are only meant to shape
you
for your purpose
you